millions of people every day live with
severe pain and it doesn't matter if you
start hurting today
or if you're dealing with an injury from
30 years ago
dr devin at spinal care of nevada and
his gentle method of chiropractic care
can help
when my back gets out of alignment it
pinches nerves
and nerve pain is pretty awful you
are just mentally exhausted from
this pain that just seems to go
like this all day long
and at times i cry sometimes it's a
lifetime of wear and tear we have old
accidents false injuries we think
nothing about
what they catch up to us down the road i
came in and i was literally hobbling in
the door
you know i was bent over i couldn't even
stand up straight my wife faye
of all it's been probably now eight
months ago
she started developing uh tiredness
fatigue
she had headaches she had nausea started
getting some adjustments
and probably after about three four
weeks she started feeling a little bit
better
noticeably so and in about two months
um magically so to speak she was fine
tanuka chiropractic
is a more gentle style of chiropractic
the the gentle approach avoids the the
twisting the cracking
or the manipulation and our patients
just prefer that
we can treat a wide range of patients
young children
people who've been in bad car accidents
bad falls maybe we've even had surgery
before
up to 80 90 year old men and women with
severe osteoporosis and arthritis so
really one of the keys to our success
is our two-day workup day one we're
going to sit down
and i'm going to listen to our patients
and i mean truly listen we'll run a
series of tests checking
every range of motion of their spine
orthopedic neurological test posture
and then we're going to take digital
opposing view x-rays these are some of
the best
type of films in our field i'm going to
study those i'm going to study the notes
so day two we're going to sit down and
i'm going to go over the findings and
listen if i can't help someone i'm going
to let them know and i'm going to get
them to the right doc if i can help
i'm very straightforward how long is it
going to take what's it going to cost
what's my insurance do or not do
because if you're anything like me you
don't want financial surprises and we're
going to get to work
and start getting some relief as soon as
possible my life's changed immensely
i'm pain-free where i used to have
shoulder neck pain i wasn't able to lift
my arms brush my own hair it's almost
like a
relief when he adjusts i can feel it
like that it's it's amazing
if you would like to see dr devin call
702-566-hope
that's 4673 or click on drdevin.com